Yo
[Musique]
encore plus nous avons du sable il y a un
spécimen unique en Amérique du Sud est le seul
pur orang-outan de Bornéo avec un
potentiel de reproduction et ainsi de suite
important pour l'espèce qui existe là où
nous avons commencé à nous concentrer sur sa vaccination et
Pensez aussi aux grands félins qui
nous savons qu'ils sont naturellement enclins à
ce problème
[Musique]
quand ce sont des comportements très compliqués
comment est l'injection par exemple que
nous savons que cela aura un ennui que
il sentira la piqûre que le prix a
être plus grand disons le
désagrément
[Musique]
l'idée est en fait de protéger
animaux les plus sensibles à
contracter le coronavirus et
aussi en même temps faire un
contrôler si le vaccin génère
immunité et combien de temps dure-t-elle
immunité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]